a year ago news about the so-called
Freedom Convoy was dominating the
headlines the trucks were allowed to
roll in and occupy the streets near
Parliament Hill for weeks and blockades
were set up at several border crossings
one year later Ottawa has a new police
chief and police are stepping up their
presence in the downtown about 500
people are expected on Parliament Hill
this weekend our chief political
correspondent David Aiken has a look at
what impact the Convoy is still having
on National politics David
well Donna I'm standing on Wellington
Street that's the street that runs right
in front of the parliament buildings and
this street has been closed to most
traffic for security reasons ever since
the freedom Convoy rolled in one year
ago I'm certainly not marking the
anniversary in any way and our Focus now
is on making sure it doesn't happen
again
some federal politicians too never wish
to see such a demonstration again that
it represented the high water mark of a
of a very extreme populist movement that
was frankly disrespectful of other
people's rights disrespectful of
diversity
disrespectful Democratic processes but
to some the protests gave a voice to
angry frustrated Canadians it brought at
least for me and a lot of people around
here hope I know everyone has their own
opinions on it but for us it's about
hope I think the significance is that
the Convoy probably never should have
had to happen but people are frustrated
in this country and they have every
reason to be that anger that frustration
continues to drive political behavior in
many parts of the country I do think if
anybody thinks what happened in the
trucker protest is going away you know
adjust your thinking it's definitely
going to be a feature in the next
federal election campaign because it
tends to work for both the Liberals and
somewhat argue for the opposition as
well Sutcliffe the Ottawa mayor hopes
for a return turn to a more civil kind
of politics I remain optimistic by
nature and and I'm hopeful that we can
that we can avoid a lot of that
nastiness but I am concerned about it
now as for this Street Wellington Street
a lot of people on city council wanted
to return to normal they want to bring
the traffic back but a lot of MPS have
some different ideas they would like to
see the federal government extend its
jurisdiction here expand the security
zone of the Parliamentary Precinct to
better protect Canada's Democratic
institutions Donna all right David Aiken
near Parliament Hill tonight thanks
David